multiply 5a minus 2 times 4a squared
plus 3a minus 1 so here we're
multiplying a binomial by a trinomial so
the foil tool will not work here it
would only work if you were multiplying
a binomial times another binomial so
here we really have to rely on the
distributive property what we can do is
we can distribute we can distribute this
entire trinomial on to the binomial so
we can multiply for a squared plus 3
minus 1 times 5 a and then multiply for
a squared plus 3 a minus 1 times
negative times negative 2 so that would
give us so that would give us let me do
it this way would be 5 a 5 8 times 4 a
squared plus 3 a minus 1 and then we
would have a negative 2 or plus negative
2 which is the same thing as let me just
write it this way plus plus negative 2
plus negative 2 times 4 a squared plus 3
a minus 1 I've just distributed this
onto each term over here you see the 5 a
minus 2 each term is now being
multiplied by this entire thing and now
we can distribute the 5 a onto this term
so we have 5a times 4a squared we see we
can multiply the 5 times a 4 we get 20 a
times a squared a to the first times a
squared is a to the third power then we
do 5 a times 3a
5 times 3 is 15 a times a is a squared
and then finally you have 5 a times
negative 1 well that's just going to be
negative 5 a now we do this part plus
negative 2 times 4 a squared negative 2
times 4 is negative 8 a squared negative
so we just did that negative 2 times 3 a
negative 2 times 3 is negative 6 a and
then finally have negative 2 times
negative 1 negative 2 times negative 1
well negative times a negative is a
positive so that is positive positive 2
and now we can combine like terms you
only have one third-degree term over
here we only have the 20 a to the
so let's just write that down 28 to the
third and then let's look let's look at
our a squared terms we have a 15 a
squared term right over here and we have
another negative 8 a squared so if I
have 15 of something and I subtract 8 if
I subtract 8 from that then I have 7 of
that something left so 15 minus 8 is 7 a
squared and then we have let me do a new
color here we have a negative 5a and to
that we're going to add a negative 6a so
we're already negative 5 we're going to
get another negative 6 we're going to
become 6 more negative so that is
negative 11a and then finally we have
this constant out here this plus 2 now
I'll show you another way to get this
exact same answer and we are done we
have simplified we've combined our like
terms another way to do this which is
essentially just doing the distributive
property twice but it's essentially more
analogous to how we actually multiply
numbers so if we do it like this we can
actually take this expression up here 4a
squared plus 3a minus 1 and then
multiply it by this second expression
right over here so times and I'll write
it in the same places when I talk about
places here I'm not talking about powers
of 10 I'm talking about powers of a so
this is in the first power of a space so
5a see we have first powers of a in this
space minus 2 this is 0th power of a
this is the a to the 0th power space
instead of the ones place this is the a
to the first power instead of the tens
place and this is a to the squared power
place instead of the hundreds place but
it's completely analogous to what you do
when you learn to multiply numbers in
the first or second grade so let's
multiply these so first let's go let's
multiply negative two times this entire
thing remember we're just essentially
doing the distributive property when I
multiply negative two times this entire
thing I'm doing this step right over
here
so negative 2 times negative 1 negative
2 times negative 1 is positive 2 and
once again there's no a there so I'm
gonna write in the a20 space or the ones
place so it's going to be positive 2
negative 2 times 3a well that is
negative 6a and it's going to be in the
a
place negative six a a to the first
power place and the negative two times
four a squared well that's just going to
be negative eight a squared negative
eight a squared so this is negative two
being multiplied by all of that gives me
this and then when I take and then when
I take my five a and I multiply it by
negative 1 that's negative five a and so
it goes into the a place so negative
five a it goes under a like term then
five eight times three eight five times
three is fifteen eight times a is a
squared so it goes under the other a
squared so it's fifteen a squared and
then finally five a times 4a squared
five times four is twenty a times a
squared is a to the third so you have
twenty a to the third and now you can
just add it all up you can just add it
all up and we get two plus nothing is to
negative 6a minus 5a well that's just
negative eleven a we still have this
plus two here negative eight a squared
plus fifteen a squared well that's going
to be seven a squared so plus 7a squared
and then you're adding this to nothing
so you have twenty a to the third and we
got the exact same answer because we
really just did the same exact thing we
just wrote it in a different way